uh we are taking calls at
davidpakman.com
slash discord let's go
next to uh jagger from chicago
jagger from chicago you're on the air
hello hello how are you
i'm pretty good how are you good uh with
trump going to florida
and such supposedly when he leaves the
white house yeah
because you know sort of thing uh
does this sort of remind you of like how
the civil war started
in terms of history of uh him going to
florida and sort of succeeding from
there in the sense of like
trump goes trump goes to the south and
maybe
generates a rebellion from like a
parallel position of leadership down at
mar-a-lago or something
yeah similar to how the civil war
started i don't think so
i really don't think so i mean you know
it's always like
if you uh i'm i'm here's the thing
that's difficult about this
i don't know if you're familiar uh
jagger with the book
uh black swans by naseem nicholas talib
have you heard of that book
i have not this nasim talib
works with the idea of rare events
and the fundamental nature of how it's
difficult to
because these black swan events are so
rare
there's no way to properly account for
them in our thinking so
like a former president going to florida
and starting
uh the equivalent of a modern
confederacy generating a civil war
because it would be such a black swan
event it's hard
to to really take it too seriously so
obviously in retrospect we may say oh my
god obviously that's what trump did it
was one of these black swan events
but it does not strike me as as
particularly likely
oh okay and do you think there's gonna
be genuine healing then in that case
genuine healing administration uh
no probably not i mean you understand
that at this point you have
such a highly weaponized piece of the
electorate
um that i mean we've had partisanship
for a long time that's not new
but you you've seen trumpism and
the uh sort of uh legitimization of some
of these propaganda right-wing media
outlets
lead to a really difficult situation to
actually heal because listen i mean we
may have an inauguration day jagger
where the news networks are broadcasting
the swearing-in of the new president
and oan and newsmax are broadcasting a
trump rally in florida and don't even
cover the fact that there's a new
president like we
we may actually see that and that's not
an environment where there's going to be
any real healing to speak of
well thank you for taking my call it's
unfortunate this is the way it is but
yeah
my pleasure thank you jagger from
chicago
uh very much appreciate hearing from you
i want to let you know that our sponsor
vincero watches is having a
massive holiday sale on all of their
products right now and you can take
advantage
of it by going to davidpakman.com
watch a brand new high quality wrist
swatch really is the perfect way
to add something fresh to your style
whether it's for you or a gift for
someone else
vincero is a brand that has a serious
dedication to the craft of watchmaking
which is really evident when you look
closely at their watches
i wear vincero watches myself lately
i've been wearing one from their icon
automatic collection it's the mesh matte
black watch and i love the sleek
minimalist design
their watches are actually sold at a
fair price their mission has always been
to make a wrist watch from high-end
materials but one that
everyday people can afford and that's
why they have over
twenty five thousand five star reviews
because you won't find a better made
watch for
this great of a price anywhere else you
can get
big holiday discounts on all of their
products right now
and free shipping when you go to
davidpakman.com
watch i've put the link right underneath
this video